en l'espace de deux jours le thermomètre
a perdu une quinzaine de degrés une
situation exceptionnelle qui n'a pas
surpris les automobilistes ce matin tu
as été ça l'est mais avec ce qui est ce
qui est retombé dessus surtout sur la
a86 là vers vélizy là ça
c'est de la livraison mais j'ai un petit
peu de retard
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est plutôt épargné par les
flocons un salage a été effectuée cette
nuit dès 4 heures du matin second
préventif à 11 heures les voies
saint-quentinoise sont restés dégager
toute la journée sans que la chaussée
soit trop glissante mais certains
automobilistes avaient anticipé le gel
je prend la précaution quand
la télé nous avise un dos neige et de
verglas d'huile et les caoutchoucs de
portières une chance que n'a pas eue la
région de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
l'autoroute a10 est fermée dans les deux
sens jusqu'à jarnier à cause d'un
accident
côté transports la sncf conseille aux
usagers de ne pas se rendre à paris ce
mardi le trafic sur la ligne lui est
interrompue depuis ce matin et de
nombreux trains ont été supprimés sur la
ligne c du rer en secours certains
courageux ont préféré prendre le vélo
pour se déplacer
se déplace eh oui mais donc prudemment
en raison de la neige des phénomènes
météo répétitives depuis le début de
l'hiver les yvelines ont connu 26 jours
de neige contre 15 pour un hiver moyen
le département a même connu cette année
six jours consécutifs de poudreuse entre
le 18 et le 23 janvier ce qui est
marquant cette année ce sont les
températures ce mardi après midi on ne
dépassait pas les moins deux degrés on
pourrait même frôlé le record de mars
1971 avec -10 5 degrés enregistrés on
attend pour la nuit prochaine en début
de matinée demain des températures de
l'ordre de - 7 à -10 degrés la semaine
dernière on avait un flux de sud qui
nous amenait des températures très
douces et là en ce début de semaine
y'avait l'anticyclone qui était situé
entre l'islande et la scandinavie a
amené en fait une masse d'air très
froide qui venaient du nord de
l'allemagne qui est venu par la belgique
les températures devraient rester froide
mercredis et jeudis vendredis matin à
noter un épisode de pluies verglaçantes
1re d'où est attendu pour ce week end
avec des températures comprises entre 4
et 8 degrés plus proches des normales de
saison et l'arrivée des traditionnelles
giboulées de mars